alors ça s'explique déjà par une très
forte fréquentation juste après le début
du confinement du site martinique pour
la première point fr on a connu à cette
période là des audiences historiques de
l'ordre de 2,8 millions pour le mois de
mars
et c'est un effet je dirais que c'est un
effet de communication le des vases
communicants tout simplement beaucoup
d'audience sur le site point d'entrée
premier point d'entrée parmi les
premiers points d'entrée sur le site
la radio en streaming donc forcément ça
induit une très forte fréquentation une
très forte écoute de notre antenne radio
en streaming 2 historiquement les radios
en période de crise on sait très bien
qu'elle
comment dire ce sont des médias
l'accompagnement les radios à ce moment
là on se dirige davantage vers la radio
et puis plus de confinement veut dire
plus de disponibilité veut dire
également plus grande écoute pour ceux
qui sont d'ailleurs ceux de la diaspora
qui nous écoutent de par le monde sont
beaucoup plus nombreux à nous écouter à
vouloir savoir ce qui se passe à la
maison ce qui se passe donc en
martinique ça situe également c'est
également l'une des deuxième raison
comme dans beaucoup de secteurs un avant
et un après kobe 19 et je crois que la
radio quand on parle de la sortie du
confinement va vraiment jouer ce rôle de
média d'accompagnement
les gens vont se poser il se pose d'ores
et déjà des questions on va tâcher
d'hermine et des experts et expertise de
spécialiste pour y répondre au mieux
permettre également aux uns et aux
autres d'avoir de retrouver peut-être
des points de repère d'avant voilà la
radio permet quelques fois de jalonner
le quotidien de tout un chacun alors
même si c'est différent on va
naturellement tirer partie 1 tiré les
enseignements de cette crise sanitaire
pour être encore plus à l'écouté de nos
auditeurs le monde du spectacle
singulièrement les chanteurs les
musiciens les artistes
ce secteur est vraiment mise à mal avec
cette crise du coc vide 19
nous avons pris le parti de privilégier
les artistes locaux les artistes du
terroir en jouant davantage alors c'est
vrai que nous nous acquittons des droits
d'auteur donc ça leur permet d'améliorer
leur situation puisque on sait très bien
que il n'ya pas de concert en ce moment
il n'y a pas de petites salles il n'y a
pas de salles dans lesquelles on peut
donner des spectacles donc c'est aussi
notre rôle que d'accompagner le monde
culturel le monde du spectacle le monde
artistique
c'est quelque chose que l'on faisait
déjà que l'on a accentué je pense
notamment à la à la pétition de cali
mais c'est tout naturellement que ça
c'est fait on le fait déjà je dirais en
temps ordinaire et bien là on a tout
simplement un petit peu plus accentué
cet effort que nous fournissons déjà au
quotidien